how does a screenwriter with no
connections break into hollywood
you gotta get some connections so
yeah um it's hard
you can't do this on your own there's
there's no
there's no formula for that
hollywood is a
company town
and it's a very very small town i think
in the book i even say it's like
mayberry which i think might be an older
reference i don't know
but it's uh everybody knows everybody
and
we're all maybe two degrees of
separation so i feel like there's not
anybody
in this town that
i can't get to within
two phone calls or emails
and i think that's you know when you've
been here long enough that's you just
know more people
and because people like to work with
people they know
you know
um they want to work with people who've
been vouched for somebody's you know a
recommendation some sort of you know
someone who's connected to someone else
because they want to make sure that you
can deliver so
there's um there's that whole factor
that that
just sort of makes that's let's just set
the table with with that right there
when you're trying to get into hollywood
you got to use the people that you do
know
and you can meet people everywhere so
there's a ton of festivals a lot of
people go to
um to festivals or panels or whatever
gatherings they can and one connection
will lead to many other connections and
i think the great thing about a lot of
the festivals these days is that
people are there because they want to
help
they want to connect i was at um austin
film festival and at this i think within
a couple weeks i was also a catalyst
that's in duluth
and
the feeling is the same so you go to
south by you go to any of these these
festivals
and there's this feeling of
we're all artists here we all are doing
the same thing we're all
uh hoping to pass along our knowledge
that's why the people show up the senior
people the the seasoned writers and
directors and and cinematographers and
everybody who's there making something
they're there to pass along losing that
knowledge there's there's a
wealth of
opportunities to
connect and make connections so start
there
you know we're now in a
in a place where now the the universe is
connected by
you know the internet and zoom
thankfully
and you can even do it from the comfort
of your own home if you're not in los
angeles
but you it does take work and it takes
work for even for me i'm constantly
reaching out to people and i've known a
lot of these people for you know i grew
up with them you know since i got out of
college and even before in high school
my first job was a hookup from a high
school friend
and every single job after that has been
a hookup from someone that i know i did
not get any of this on my own not a
single position was a blind call
so
that's how it works for most
people even if you are not
i use the pal chose a lot but even if
you're not a pal cho you're not sitting
around the table as a kid learning from
your father and your mother how to
navigate the situation
even if you don't have that you're not
connected and there's no nepotism that
you can draw on
you can do it i did it my parents were
in the dental field my mom was a dental
hygienist when i was growing up she then
taught dental hygiene
and then she went on to become a dean of
college and my dad was obviously uh my
stepdad was a dentist
so
i i was only connected through
the friend that i had who
was working for delores robinson at the
time that's all i had
and it worked
so
um
you have to have you have to rely on
those connections they will get you your
first and your last job
so then in a sense you would have to be
out here to make those connections or
know in today's
world you could make them social media
both i think i think it's
at a certain point you do
if you really want to supersize your
career you sort of should be in los
angeles now again that is a
pre-pandemic mindset now it's
post-pandemic maybe
we're getting there
so there may be a factor where we will
come back to in person i prefer in
person
um because there's just a you vibe off
of people very differently
than you do over zoom where you just
have a you know i've got a glass in
front of me you've got a glass in front
of you and there's just this this
weird
chasm between us of
whatever the internet is fiber
microfibers or whatever so we're we are
in this situation where
we are forced to create relationships
that that aren't real relationships
we're forced to do that but when you're
sitting in front of somebody and you're
having a meeting or you're doing
breakfast lunch or dinner and you are
really connecting and it's not you don't
have a time clock on you you know you
don't have your zoom's not going to run
out in 30 minutes but you really have a
chance to get to know someone and hear
about their lives and what do they you
know what kind of
what do they like to eat on their
spaghetti whatever it is there's a
something that happens when we are
creating those relationships and those
friendships and then you have to nurture
those you have to keep them up so how
you're going to do it you have to
schedule another zoom
so is it doable of course it's doable
everything's doable and there's no right
and wrong answers at all it all works
but
it's a little harder
it's it's
people have to know you
and then people have to be able to
connect you with other people that they
know
and it's easier to do that when you are
in one place
and in the book i say look you know the
the trick of it is is that if you live
somewhere outside of los angeles and
again we're talking about in-person
events
you're outside of los angeles and you
come to la
two weeks out of the year
well then everybody who you are relying
on to connect you with other people have
to work their schedules around you
and they have to try to figure out how
to fit everybody that they want to
connect you with
into that two-week frame
and at time frame and and that's it's a
it's not fair to anybody on on any side
um
and it's and usually those meetings get
canceled it's canceled all the time a
friend of mine used to carry mccool used
to call it cancelicious she used to say
oh your lunch is canceled it's
cancellous so
yeah you're gonna have to come into
a
situation where
you are available at the drop of a hat
and you might find that there's a party
or there's a screening or there's a
gathering at the academy
that you want to go to and it's
happening tomorrow night and if you have
to book a flight
and you can't get in
then
you're not going to be at the party with
the rest of us so
some at some point
you have to figure out a way to do it
in the meantime though there's a lot of
prep you can do you can create a social
media profile you can make relationships
that way
you always have to be a value add to
whoever you're reaching out to just
don't ask them for hey can i
you know can you read a screenplay of
mine then the answer is always going to
be no
but
um
but you have to figure out a way to to
create a
a relationship long distance
what if someone's like this hot young
writer let's say on the east coast and
they have an imdb pro account and
they've gone through the top 30 and then
they've filtered out the next top 30
they're sending these queries out
and they're just here for a short time
is that really going to work though
because in some ways it's disingenuous
because you're just like hey i'm here
let's network i.e help me out help me
get to the next level sure and people in
l.a that have been here a while or have
grown up here as you have they can smell
that a mile away and it's off-putting
because
you're like oh they need me for
something yeah it's not because they
want to hang out with me right well
those are those are the really that's
again that's not nurturing relationship
that's that's being very transactional
it's i need something from you and i and
again you're talking about somebody
who's not offering something
except maybe finding the next big thing
but everybody thinks the next big thing
so and we've heard that so many times
and then we've been burned by it so many
times like you read the scripture you go
nah that's not that great
so we we are very cautious about how
we're going to spend our time and what
we're going to um
you know if you're i'm going to crack
open your script and spend an hour
reading your script
i want someone to have vouched for you i
want somebody who've told me hey this is
worth it so i'm probably not going to
take your word for it because you think
you're brilliant
and i might not think you're ready yet
not that you aren't going to be
brilliant eventually but maybe you
aren't brilliant enough for whatever
opportunity i might have
so
yeah you gotta you have to figure out um
a better way to do that and i think the
good gauges then enter a competition
enter a program get a little vouching
for
buy somebody who we already have bought
into their level of
taste
so when you're anointed by sundance then
we know there's a bar you know
you've just sort of leaped frog over
a lot of other steps so you could do it
that way
so get noticed get known
where you are
right and on the flip side and i'd
realize i took a negative slant with
that and on a different slant i saw a
woman on screenwriting twitter say you
know i just want to say to all the
screenwriters out there who haven't
gotten work from screenwriting twitter
to not feel badly because so many people
are promoting that hey i just landed
this and i just you know and it's all
looking so rosy and she said a lot of
people can then feel bad because they're
not getting that she's like i've gotten
two
possible job offers and none of them
happened and i just want people to know
don't think that it's you because it's
it's a small percentage what do you
think about that i love that she did
that i think that's
that's terrific again that's why i love
screenwriting twitter i love those
those threads because people are very um
very kind and very supportive and we
they all know how hard it is and there
are a lot of people who are on that who
are very successful
who are saying look it's hard for me too
and careers take you know go ups and
down have ups and downs and not
everything's rosy and people do tend to
filter all of the negativity because
they don't want to seem like they're
complaining or you know that they're
they're not
making it happen when so many other
factors go into whether somebody sells
something at that moment or don't or or
doesn't sell it
so yeah i do think i i would say to
everybody take heart
um if you read um stephen king's on
writing
it's you know he was like he'd gotten so
many rejection letters i think you know
there's so many people out there who
have had that experience where it just
feels like it's
sisyphus trying to roll that boulder up
a hill
and you aren't getting anywhere and and
then eventually you do or you find
another way
to
make your inroads or you find a
different
level not a level um
definition of success
and again not everyone's going to write
a marvel movie
nor should everyone want to write a
marvel movie
but if that's your barometer for success
and you are missing all the other
opportunities out there
then
you have to figure out why are you a
writer in the first place what are you
trying to do
what do you want to accomplish
but i do feel as though that's that was
that's i love that she is
out there
um
singing the truth because that's
important for people to acknowledge
you know it's not all roses
but the the great part about
writing is that
it is
in itself a reward
so regardless of whether or not
i ever sell anything
again
as a writer
the writing itself for me when i write
something really good that i think is is
um that i enjoy
that i want to go back to and read again
then i feel as though there's that at
least i have that
and then hopefully everything else you
know you want to make money you want to
you want to make a living that would be
really awesome
but yeah you have to figure it out for
yourself
well and then to on writing with stephen
king there was another part to that book
which was
he'd established himself but now
he was needing to
[Music]
you know live a certain lifestyle in
order to churn out pages and and
changing that as well so that's
something that everyone just thinks if i
can just get to this part but what about
sustaining that part so that's something
that no we don't want to hear that part
because it's all going to be magical
once we get there right that don't worry
about me i'll be fine well
we see the challenge in front of us we
don't always see and we don't always
know what's going to be after that
you know that's another little thing
that you go oh i i didn't realize
once i stepped over the cliff i didn't
realize oh there's another
whole mountain that i have to climb